good evening welcome to this meeting of
the planning committee
my name is councillor bill fleming and
i'm the chairman for this meeting
just a little bit of housekeeping
committee members when invited to
address
okay we've got a live microphone
somewhere that should be switched off
all right is it yours carol okay
sorry committee members when invited to
address the meeting please ensure your
microphone is switched
on so that it picked up via the live
audio feed
when you've finished addressing the
meeting please turn off your microphone
immediately
please ensure that you've switched off
or to silent any other devices that you
may have that may interrupt the meeting
live broadcast we please note that this
meeting is also being broadcast live
and members of the public not in
attendance today
are able to view the proceedings
offices present today and
we'll start with caroline nash committee
administrator
dale barker planning manager my role is
to
advise members
ross chambers legal services
i'm amy fleets planning officer sarah
mcpherson planning officer
louise coleman planning officer
okay we're done
note for public speakers public speakers
were given a 30 second warning during
their speaking time
once you've finished speaking the
committee may wish to ask you some
questions
so please remain seated if there are no
more questions
you can leave the table ensuring your
your mask is left on
and you have wiped the table with a wipe
provided but we got wipes on the table
yeah we have
okay right we'll now move on to the
agenda
agenda item one apologies have we
received any apologies
chairman apologies from councillor
richards councillor kendall
councillor adam and councillor eden
thank you
thank you very much
agenda item two disclosures of interest
do any committee members have any
interest they would like to declare
in relation to items on the agenda
council crumb thank you chairman um i'm
board member
for application 2101274 if you are
welfare center cravenline southern
and i've registered to speak so i won't
be taking them any part in that debate
and
until it's my time to speak thank you
declaration from myself um on the item
for 87 high street bidford i haven't
i'm not the ward member for it but i'll
be speaking on behalf of the objectives
so i'll
exclude myself from the debate and the
vote on that one
minutes do i have a proposal and a
second or for minutes held
on the 7th of july yeah
proposed by cancer mills secondly my
counselor
jenny's that was it
thank you for that
okay move on to the planning
applications
agenda item four application number two
zero
oblique stroke 02 839 of release soak
fuel
land near to bishop sichington stratford
on haven
i invite the planning officer louise
coleman to present the application
please
thank you luis
right the site is located approximately
490 meters south of bishops at tington
and 480 metres north of nightcote
village
and identified by the black dot on the
map
the site which is marked with a red line
is approximately 82.5 hectares of
agricultural land made up of nine fields
two public rights of way but above the
south
the site's south eastern corner and
further public footpaths are located in
the vicinity
identified by the green hatch lines most
notable
are those within christmas hill and
piper's hill which is situated
approximately 1.9 kilometers to the west
those within the burden dacit hills to
the south
together with a centenary way identified
by the pink dotted line
old town farmhouse which is a grade two
listed building is located
where my arrow is approximately 260
meters to the east
and also the grade two listed and
scheduled ancient monument
beacon tower identified by the star here
um and also the grenington hill camp
which is just off here
are located within the burden dacit
hills approximately
2.9 kilometers to 3 kilometers to the
south
within the site itself it's mainly
located within flood zone 1
however there is area within flood zones
two
and three this is primarily outside the
site edged in red
but there is some extending within this
zone
this is the layout plan showing the
landscaping
the proposal seeks to construct a solar
farm with supporting equipment within
56.8 hectares of the site
for a temporary 40-year period the
anticipated capacity of the solar farm
is 49.9 megawatts
in connection to the grid is proposed by
underground cabling
along nikep road and the b4551
over a distance of approximately 2.5
kilometers
the panels themselves have a maximum
height of 2.7 meters
and 0.9 at their lowest point perimeter
fencing around the site is 2.02 meters
in height
cctv cameras mounted on five point uh
touch
2.5 meter high poles and there's also
associated building structures and
plants
but a maximum height of 4.1
meters the arrangements of the panels
are shown in the layout plan
and existing hedge tree planting around
the boundaries of the fields
and the perimeters of the site are
largely being retained and supplemented
in areas
especially along the south eastern
corner of the area
of the site here
this is a zoomed in plan
of the proposals an access point
is proposed in the northern section of
the site adjacent to the boundary with
blue barn stables
with a new internal access road
and a dnl dno substation located about
11 meters behind
the proposed hedge line uh an
access is also proposed to utilize an
existing
um entrance um in the southern part of
the site
and a temporary construction compound is
proposed within the
hatched yellow area here this would be
in position for a temporary period of
around about
three months
turning now to the visibility splays in
order to achieve
the necessary displays a section of
hedgerow identified in pink here
would need to be removed but you'll see
that
the area in green is proposed new hedge
planting
which would be behind it and this is
further identified
within this plan here
this is photographs so um
self-explanatory that's the visibility
to the south
and the visibility display to the north
looking now to the sudden display again
there would be
a requirement so this is the access
point here
there would be a requirement for an area
of a hedgerow to be removed
however again being replanted along here
just to note here the gap here there is
an existing footpath that runs alongside
this area here
this is a photograph as you can see the
existing
access and visibility display to the
north that will be unaffected
but the south it's around this section
of here
which would need to be removed and but
however
replanted turning now to some
photographs of the sites
you'll be able to orientate yourselves
by the map at the
the base here so this is me looking
towards um from nike bottoms so
the start of the solar farm is behind
this hedgerow here
and then this is the view from the
public footpath sma
so sm 85a along
from nike's bottom and then
this is a view a long night cut bottoms
so this is behind this hedgerow here it
was the start of
zone what they defined as zone five of
the solar farm
this is a view if you're looking here
looking directly towards
zone five here so as you can see it's
quite exposed at the moment
and so new hedgerow planting which is
going to be allowed to grow to up to
three
meters in height is proposed um
you'll see this further on from the
photograph that i've just shown you
new hedgerow planting is also proposed
along this
area here where the footpath
currently runs
now this is taken so i'm from the
footpath
looking back um and suddenly direction
towards
nightcap bottoms and nightcut road so
this is the area where the solar panels
will be going this is the new hedgerow
that will be
installed
this is a view looking towards the west
so the zone identified as zone 3 would
be behind here
this would still have panels in here
um now i've gone to um
sorry i've got the screen it's covering
it oh you can't see it doesn't matter
um around here i can show you
this this is christmas hill and piper's
hill
and um these are views uh from
years one and five um showing
the solar panels um one the solar farm
and from that vista
this is a view from beacon tower
looking towards the site and so this is
in a
northerly direction
and this is a view from burton dassett
hills
away from the tower but this is a year
one and a year five so this is the area
where we're looking at here
and that's the end of the presentation
chairman there are a number of
updates to report historic england
have confirmed no objections to the
development on the historic
asset grounds and then the llfa have
also removed their objections
and the recommendation is to grant
subject to the conditions and notes as
detailed in the report
thank you chair
thank you luis thank you for that we've
got
quite a few speakers on this one
and first one we go to is uh
councillor steve tressier cessler sorry
uh bishop teaches in paris council
objecting
uh counselor tesla you've got three
minutes
we'll uh we'll give you a 30-second
warning
okay start when you're ready
can you turn on your microphone please
okay can you hear me now okay
the parish council objects the size and
location of proposed development
which contradicts several policies in
the course strategy
the committee reports concurs the parish
council's view
that the application contradicts
policies in the core strategy in terms
of scale
visual impact and sustainability
most significantly the proposal can
contradicts policy cs3
on sustainable energy
we would like the following to be
considered
impact on agricultural activities and
disturbances to agricultural land
the land in question has been product
has been productivity for decades
in fact centuries for growing crops
impact on the openness and character of
the landscape
on a visual immunity the impact is
enormous
topography of the site the impact
is greater than of the proposed deposit
bridge solar farm
also in the field and veil
which was refused and subsequently
dismissed
at appeal in 2015
grounds through refusal and dismissal in
this case were unacceptable
harmed to the landscape character and
visual appearance
of the area based mainly on nppf
policies on which the sdc's planning
policies now stand
those same grounds exist for this site
impact on the character of the historic
landscape
archaeological archaeological surveys
conducted
for this application have shown that the
site is an extremely rich historic
landscape
dating back to roman and saxon times
policy cs3 states that proposals
will be determined with regard to the
council's renewable energy
landscape sensitivity assessment to
assess the capacity and sensitivity
of the landscape to accommodate the
scheme
this assessment states that the
proposals proposed
site being over 25 hectares and in the
field and veil farmlands has immediate
medium to high sensitivity
to solar energy developments it
specifically
highlights the sensitivity of the area
visible from burton dassett country park
which this is it is for the committee to
decide
in which to uphold core strategy
planning policies
or risk setting a precedent which could
lead to inappropriately large
solar farms occupancy occupying vast
areas of agricultural land in the
district
this development is too large in this
location to be sustainable
so you've had your time now councillor
so
[Music]
we really need to sort of wrap it up at
this point okay as it contradicts many
core strategy policies especially cs3
renewable energy thank you for your time
this evening thank you
hang on a minute
does anybody have any questions for the
counsellor
thanks nicer crumb
oh yeah i mean he's a county councillor
for the last i've got to
give you something here um i know just
the joint consultation response from
yourselves and burton dussett
um said that some residents at burton
dussette
had missed out some other as part of the
consultation
was that the same for bishop washington
as well did you or was that okay
did you the consultation response and
the applicant's
agents have carried out a number of
consultation events however the father
to deliver invitations to the correct
addresses are missing out residents of
burton's asset
price um meant that some of them mistake
the opportunity to respond
was it the same for bishop tichington as
well or was the consultation okay
consultation was taken um i think there
probably is improvement
in in the in in the detail that we need
to review
i don't i wouldn't say everyone has been
consulted
as they should have been okay thank you
any other questions for the council
nope okay thank you very much for that
now say now we have uh
mrs lynn pearson a resident and cynthia
bethany resident
you've got three minutes between you you
can do half each or however you want to
do this
do you want us to give the one and a
half minutes and then the 30 seconds to
the end
who's gonna start we've both cut ours
down
the fact that i was told i could have
three minutes to myself a few days ago
is actually set this
alarm bells ringing this evening because
i just found out i haven't got three
minutes i've got one and a half
but if mrs bettenly would like to start
off i will try and
leave out a lot of my points and uh
concentrate on the main
oh yeah so whoever wants to start start
my pleasure
um this is cynthia bettany i'm vice
chair of burton dassett parish council
burton does the parish council continues
to object to the proposal
the burton asset country park is
designated as an sla
the broadview wind farm proposed on the
same land was rejected because of visual
impact the proposal fails a site
size sensitivity test a 15 to 25 hectare
site is considered to be medium to high
how does an application for 82.5
hectares fit in with this framework
it exceeds the framework by over 250
quoting from the white study which is
referred to in your
cs3 as part of the council's renewable
energy landscape sensitivity study
feldenvale farmlands it states and i
quote
the scale of a development is
recommended generally to
small to medium to avoid adverse effects
on the topography
landscape pattern and settlements thank
you
thank you very much nate for you to
carry on thank you
the development would be a large
industrial site in the center of a rural
tourist area
the construction of which would go
against the strategic aims of the
council's own core
strategy i quote the rural character of
the district will have been maintained
and enhanced
the green belt and the countryside will
have been protected from inappropriate
development
a new development will take into account
the intrinsic and special values of the
landscape
this development of over 80 hectares
will totally alter the ethos of the area
it generates four quart mile loop of a
2.4 meter high solid
metal fencing bearing more than 150 ccd
cameras placed
50 meter intervals more in a city than
rural
the areas clay baseland and site floods
regularly during periods of wet weather
a substantial part of the report
submitted by the applicants themselves
could not be completed during due to
flooding
last week the government announced
developers are to be borrowed from
building on land at risk of flooding
therefore the application should not
even be under consideration
the veldin redfelden veil is an
established migratory route for
overwintering birds which fly at night
during migration periods
reflection from panels during a full or
partial moon would make the entire site
resemble a lake or small group of ponds
birds attempting to land to rest or
refuel would be injured or killed and
could damage panels
the applicant's proposal states that
once the site has been cleared from
prime agricultural land
and the panels installed a
glycotype-based herbicide already banned
in the eu
will be used on areas to be seeded with
grass to restrict weed growth
this weed killer is deadly to bees and
flying insect life
and in a recent study in taiwan 2019
it has shown that this is a high cancer
risk once in the water system
the application goes against these own
core strategy and government policy it
would harm the local area immensely and
be an eyesore it should not go ahead
thank you very much thank you does any
of the
members have any questions for either of
the speakers
councilor curtis thank you chad
um i'm sorry obviously you're speaking
very quickly
to get in no no that that's most helpful
i wouldn't mind i find it helpful if you
could just
say something again about the herbicide
yes please
right i'm a beekeeper recently this um
particular glyphosate based herbicide
was tried to
uh be used in east anglia to um
cut kill the areas around the sugar beet
crop because of infestation
the government looked at it and banned
it because of the report
saying that it did have a high cancer
risk once in the water system
and if you have a look at the taiwan
university study of 2019 on the internet
it will show you that there is a high
cancer risk once this gets into
groundwater
sorry and just for clarification it's
it's proposed that this this herbicide
would be used on this side to spray the
clear the land
and then once a year it will be used to
keep the weeds down
case addiction yeah thank you
you mentioned there the uh glyphosate
and the
area of sugar beet production did
anything in that report
basically say it was banned or not
not required because it was a food
production area
no it's deadly blind intersection
so it wasn't the fact that it was a
sugar pig
margins of the sugar big fields down
using this but yeah i think you were
referring pups to leeching as well
yes leeching i mean it's a flood area
and it goes straight into the river
can i just ask a question myself um
this this herbicide if it's banned in
east anglia was it not a nationwide ban
or is it
expand in europe it's not banned in this
country now that we're out of the eu
so um the government had to look at it
again
after um the british beekeeping
association
actually contacted them about it and
they looked again at the
proposal and said no you can't use it
okay thank you very much thank you
so
right hand our next speakers are uh
for the applicants and our supporters
we've got mr james hartley
bond the agent and mrs pat hudson
resident
chair if i may um mrs pat hodson
isn't here tonight um but if members
refer to their update sheet on page two
they'll see her her written comments are
there and they just go over onto page
three
and her reason for not being present
he's also quite clearly there
on the update sheet thank you
so james hartley bond the agent you
actually have six minutes if you should
need them
thank you chair councillors ladies and
gentlemen
my name is james hartley bond i'm the
head of project development
at low carbon i'm not going to try and
convince you this evening that there's
no impact on the proposal before you
we like your officer recognize there are
both impacts
and significant benefits from the
proposal and your officer has carefully
considered
and weighed these in her report we
commend the detail and comprehensiveness
of the report
and it's noted that this is a balanced
judgment in favor of the proposal
with benefits outweighing the impacts
these are the reasons why
that we consider this the right
recommendation
firstly it's important to note that the
proposal has evolved as a consequence of
technical studies
community engagement and discussions
with your officers and statutory council
teas
as such there are no unresolved
technical concerns from statutory
council teas
the process of evolution has also meant
that we have been able to
pull the development back from sensitive
areas around neighbouring properties
plus through careful sighting and
landscaping
mitigate views from local and distant
vantage points
including burton dassett country park as
you have heard
which is approaching three kilometers
from the site
whilst the development cannot be made
invisible we agree with your landscape
officer
that the proposal would result in few
significant
harmful visual imp effects for such a
sizable site
so to our mind it boils down to the more
subjective matters of landscape and
visual impact
weighed against the significant benefits
of the proposal
as noted by your landscape officer the
veil farmlands in which the proposal is
situated
is identified in the council's renewable
landscape sensitivity study
as the main landscape out of 20 others
in the district most able to accommodate
solar development
without extensive landscape character
harm so in other words
all other 19 landscape types in the
district were assessed as being of
greater sensitivity
and thereby less suitable than this area
whilst we understand the concerns over
scale officers consider that the
proposal
can be assimilated successfully here as
members will know
the council has declared a climate
emergency and events of the last few
weeks and months
are showing as the frequency and
severity of such events are increasing
both at home and abroad
meaning that collective action must be
taken this proposal represents a
significant opportunity
to help with this emergency and in
providing enough clean energy
for over 25 of the district's homes it
will help with the council's ambitions
on its journey to
journey to net zero to this end i
respectfully ask that you approve the
application
thank you
thank you very much um does anyone have
any questions for mr hartley bond
okay okay um good evening
um with the consultation with the parish
councils or
or residents there were
yes so so um on to that point exactly
just to provide a bit of clarity
um we the first consultation that we
undertook
there was there was an error in that
process and there was
uh there were a couple of things there
was an error in the um
an admin error internally but also an
error with the distribution so we used a
bespoke distribution company to um to
basically they do hand dropped mail
drops
and it turns out that certain properties
were missed there is a new development
on the edge of
bishop sexington that wasn't in the in
the area originally because it's a new
development
we then held our hands up and and so one
of the consequences of that is that we
actually
run a second consultation used different
means of
of of distributing the mail so royal
mail
and essentially the consultation was
then run over about two months so
so we fully held our hands up about the
first error but we hope that
during the course of the two months that
the consultation was undertaken that
that provided sufficient opportunity
can i go and and the response on that
on your consultation um so broadly
um so probably slightly more uh against
um a chunk in the middle that we we sort
of measure neutral responses and then
uh probably a third or so or just over a
third that were there were for the
proposal
um but that's probably not atypical of a
response
um we certainly had a large number of
people that
we use an online platform um which
also tells us about the number of
visitors to the project and
the number of visitors um far outweighed
the actual number of comments
and depending what you're feeling is
around people that are informed
um it tends to be the the sort of people
that feel more strongly about objecting
that follow through with an objection
in our experience
thank you very much cancer addiction
thank you chairman um
when i see solar farms from above they
tend to look to my mind a lot of
solar panels on the field now
essentially
there is possible archaeological impact
and therefore
such could be impacted when the
a solar farm is constructed
i was just wondering in actual fact how
much construction
how much ground movement is there in
actual fact in creating
this and also um obviously we've heard
about the site plans
uh sight lines and i wondered when it's
all set up
are there many vehicle movements because
i would again anticipate it's something
that you know
generates electricity when the sun
shines um
and also we've heard of obviously the
concerns regarding glyphosate
which i equate with roundup though i
dare say
industrial and business users possibly
might have something a bit more stronger
than roundup to use um but we've seen
that there
are new hedgerows to be planted i
believe it is intention obviously to
plant grass
under the panels when it's all sorted if
sorted etc
so what would be your anticipation of
the
biological benefits if any should we be
minded to
to grant the the request
yeah thank you um several great
questions um so happy to answer those
i'll do my best to
i think recall them all but um so
archaeology firstly yes
it's something we tend to find is for
every site we look at
um there's a there's a process that we
go through in terms of investigating
um and it can be multi-layered so
initially there's a desk-based
assessment here
uh followed by a geophysical survey and
if
we're fortunate enough to receive an
approval there will be further work in
the form of
most likely in the form of trial
trenching um so but to date what we've
learned is that through the geophysical
survey in particular
it shows certain areas where there are
where there's more prevalence of um
significant features and those are
subsequent to that they have been
excluded from the scheme
so um and then in terms of that more
general impacts on archaeology um
essentially you're looking at
um its piling for the for the steel
framework so
what unlike say a housing estate for
instance we're not concreting huge areas
or excavating large areas so
so there's always scope there's i guess
minimal damage in that respect and scope
to adjust around those
features just to give you some comfort
um
in terms of vehicles if that was more
around
trip generation generally to the site so
so once
one of the things with solar is that
once construction is complete
generally you're looking at between
three four vehicles perhaps
a week and that will typically be a car
or possibly a transit van or something
similar
so so very limited um ongoing
maintenance
visits um in terms of the glycosa
um that was that was obviously mentioned
um look it really depends there are a
number of ways of managing sites
um and you know there are we're always
looking at so what we actually look
after about 20
of the uk solar farms from an asset
management and operations and
maintenance point of view
so of course if the substance is banned
then
clearly that that that wouldn't be used
anyway um
we're always looking for improvements in
the in the way that science can be
managed
and one of the things on this site we
actually make provision for
cheap grazing so one of the things we're
actually looking at is
sheep predominantly keeping a lot of the
the the grassland down
um and in terms of i mean believe it or
not we actually have beehives on sites
that we
that we operate so we actually produce
our own honey
um and uh biodiversity net gain
has has long been an issue for us that
that um and we've always believed that
that we can
deliver significant gains through these
projects um
you may be familiar that the environment
built um that's coming in
this year is looking um for all
development of all types to provide
a 10 target for biodiversity net gain
and one of the really good things
okay um but we see it as a positive just
around biodiversity net gain is we're
able to now capture that
um and just from looking at two sides so
far where this has started to be asked
for
we're running at about 40 to 50 on
average biodiversity net gain
excellent thank you very much uh
councillor crump meet you too
matt i'll let him go first age before
beauty man
um yeah very briefly um sounds like
you've got a lot of experience in this
microphone microphone's kind of
the luxury that's better no it's all
right i think my battery is all right
uh the um one of the
objectives mentioned migratory birds and
the issue
um reflection at night from moonlight et
cetera
and i think in her words will they land
or
refuel potentially causing injuries to
the birds and panel damage
um if you've got an experience on that
and if you do what mitigating
mitigation do you put in place please
yeah and it's another good question um
the reality is solo is still a
relatively new technology but but
certainly in our experience
it's not something we've seen a
particular problem with um
we um we have sites near estuaries and
and
wetland areas as well so it's something
that we
um for those projects there are
sometimes areas of mitigation we can
provide in the form of things like
hedgerows to just break up
the appearance of vast areas of solar
for instance and one of the things with
this site it is broken down already into
sort of several smaller uh fields
rather than one sort of single large
field so
those types of features tend to be the
things that actually helps create uh
create the the awareness that that that
there is
you know that the birds don't tend to be
attracted in that respect
okay let's try and get through this
quickly just two questions for you
how many houses will this provide energy
for
um and the second question is and i
looked on the off gems
uh figures about um energy uh supply and
it looked like 74
was gas and coal 20 nuclear and only
four percent is
of renewables that was a couple of years
ago couldn't find up-to-date details
how much is supplied by the renewables
or solar sector now
yep so um just just on the first point
so um the number of houses uh is around
about 16 and a half thousand
um in term and the second point just in
terms of um
in terms of energy it's it's it's been
growing year on year so the wider
renewable energy industry um
is probably typically 30 um or but it's
it's started to exceed coal
um in certain years it's been exceeding
nuclear generation as well so
renewables as a whole is significant and
solar is
um one of the uh well the significant
part of that
alongside both onshore and offshore wind
thank you thank you council curtis you
want to go again
um just very quickly if i may um said
that
it will provide following council
johnny's point
um 16 and a half thousand homes we
should all be playing our part
in supporting renewables
will does this electricity go into the
national grid
though i think just for clarification on
that point please
yeah of course again another good
question so um in terms of how it works
the the project is connected into
western power distributions network
which is the network which
you will all which which everyone is
connected to locally
um the connection point that was talked
about is the substation at harbory
um just up the road um what
we've we've basically moved away from a
transmission based system with lots of
large power stations so
one of the things that all we are we're
all living with a lot more localized
projects such as this
they connect in that local level and the
power is
tends to be used closest to where the
demand is in the first instance so
if there's less demand it may go further
afield but it but it's not the case that
it
like a transmission based power station
that is designed to go 100 miles to
manchester or or beyond
uh just a question i don't know welcome
back to you in a minute peter just what
i want to get
um i people say and it's here say
that these solar farms um they give off
a hum or a noise or whatever else
can you clarify what kind of a noise
whether it's a nuisance value or what it
is please
yeah okay so um the only thing that
really makes any noise on a solar pharma
are the inverters so an inverter is what
essentially converts the dc
power that's generated by the panels
into into ac so that it can be exported
into the grid
um and within those inverters you also
have a transformer
um so they're in containerized units um
and
they tend to be cited and we've designed
them to be fairly central within the
site
so that um the the the
the panels essentially provides a noise
attenuation
uh filter to that as well so as and as
you get further and further away
um once you're around the periphery of
the site you're generally down to levels
which is pretty similar to a whisper in
the library
so whilst it's louder in the very center
of the site if you were stood next to an
inverter
when you're on the periphery it's not
it's barely audible
occasionally you're seraphin thank you
jeff
just a quick uh question um
figures i've got here said four and a
half miles of fencing
what type of fencing is it
yeah so um fencing wise we use a two
meter high
post and wire fence so sort of like a
deer stock uh if you're familiar with
um so not sort of palisade or high
security fencing or anything of that
nature
they're not solid funnels no so no this
is this is post and wire so so
with fairly large um sort of uh sections
within the actual wire so so fairly
visible through
okay thank you
catch the mills yeah thank you um
just my benefit uh are the um is it more
efficient in the summer than the winter
i mean
i'm when we got sunny or bad weather
yeah
yeah so absolutely um it so solar farms
will generate
on overcast days um but there's just
simply more daylight
and some essentially sun hours in the
summer months so
so it it's with over a season if you
sort of imagine a sort of a bell curve
for production
um but even on some clear winter days
you can still get a reasonable amount of
production that
yes absolutely it's it's more geared
around summer
okay thank you very much any further
questions
no okay thank you very much you're now
sort of free to go
next speakers board member council chris
kettles
okay you have five minutes we'll give
you a warning
when you're getting close
thank you um
all right climate change is a crisis
that this council and i recognise along
with the need for renewable energy
and i i personally have eight acres of
solar panels on my farm
however we should not have a new jerk
reaction to support a renewable energy
application
in this district instead we need to
respond in a measured way
i object to this application for three
reasons the loss of a significant area
of productive
agriculture land scale and the visual
impact
to a historic landscape in 2019
hsbc reported that 8 of our food is
imported
including meat and vegetables in the
southern hemisphere and sainsbury's
selling onions grown in new zealand
all of which could be grown in the uk
what is the carbon footprint of land
from new zealand or south america
meanwhile we have a growing population
which 11 according to the u.n are
starving
it is equally critical for the uk to
source and grow food
sustainably yet between april and
september 2020 127 new large-scale solar
farms were open to the uk
in my county division there are already
three solar farms of 151 acres
with a capacity of 29 megawatts out of
11 in the whole district
if this and two other large-scale farms
proposed in harbor are approved the area
lost in the felden division alone will
be 790 acres
according to the department
ah let's back up back on anyway
right it is now back on
i didn't touch it it just
right where are we time-wise
um and right renewables already provided
43
of the uk electricity and now generate
more electricity than fossil fuels
in 2020 wind generated 49
of our renewable energy biomass plants
26
and solar only 10 why does this matter
because the footprints of wind and
biomass plants are negligible
but soda takes over hectares of land
that we can ill afford to use
sheffield university published a study
in 2017 that showed the in the uk
non-irrigated arable land now only
represents 20
27 of the uk land mass arable land is a
valuable resource we need to feed this
nation
and wind and biomass plants are far more
effective generated renewable energy and
solar
this may be grade b land but as is most
warwickshire
it is not unproductive land and has been
successfully continued to crop for many
years in terms of policy
cs2 says measures to mitigate the impact
of climate change will include direct
directing development of sustainable
locations cs3 says provision will be
made for a range of renewable energy
to maximize environmental social and
economic benefit whilst
minimizing any adverse local benefits
and the overall
balance should be positive for local
communities where the proposal affects
the listed building the cotswold aonb
or non-design designated heritage and
cultural assets
the objective of the designation must
not be compromised by the development
further solar development will be
assessed against agricultural activities
the openness and character the landscape
and visual immunity
and the character historic landscape
this site stretches one and a half miles
by half a mile wide
it faces and is overlooked by the burton
dassett hills country
park including a listed norman church
15th century beacon tar
anglo-saxon cemetery and is adjacent to
the iron age grendelson hill ford
the park attracts thousands of visitors
every year the applicant's own planning
statement
states the proposal is extensive in
scale and the solar panels will be
highly visible in the landscape
the proposed will temporarily change the
rural character and appearance of the
business of
the um of local viewpoints and from long
distances
including the burton desert country park
and the cotswold aonb
the scale of the proposal could
significantly change the rural
appearance
inspector cook refused to appeal for a
solar farm at deputy bridge within my
ward
commenting that the ppg recognized that
the develop deployment of large-scale
solar farms
can have a negative effect on the rural
environment particularly in undulating
landscapes his reason for refusal was
the harm to the landscape
overweighed the benefits of solar farm
inspector parsons allowed an appeal at
blackwell
referring to the council's landscape
sensitivity study
which states that felden farmland has
sensitive to solar development where it
is open and close to adjacent hillsides
allowing inter visibility this includes
the cotswold ao and b
in conclusion the generation of the
right renewable energy is an important
part of the climate agenda
but this application with a country park
the aonb
overlooking the site taking a very large
area of arable land well in excess of
the 25 hectares you've heard about
previously
is an application in the wrong place and
more importantly
the wrong size and it looks directly
at a country park which is regularly
visited by very many people
thank you mr thank you
thank you uh anybody have any questions
for cancer cattle
thank you council cattle um as a
an agricultural farmer i believe
there was mention made that they could
possibly use sheep on this land
as well as the solar panels have you any
experience
in that area and have you any uh
information and knowledge that you could
park
to us as to the effectiveness of grazing
sheep
amongst solar panels and the appeal at
depp's bridge
do you know the date of that i'm just
wondering if prior to the core strategy
or prior to the declaration of climate
change
i can answer the latter um easily it was
before
the course strategy was actually adopted
but whilst this course strategy was
still being
developed and therefore was a planning
consideration at the time
i cannot recall um the second blackwell
application was more recent
uh and i think was post-court strategy
um
mr barker might comment on that i can't
quite remember
that's the appeal date i think was 2017
on that one i can't quite remember the
appeal date on the
on the um bridge one um in terms of
sheep
um this has been arable land for
40 years um there is a sign as i've said
i have a solar panel which is not mine
it's
involved by an institution there's a
large sign when the when
we have visitors with the pictures of
sheep
um i have never seen um or had any
request by that particular developer to
put sheep on the land
it is known uh on a regular basis
to solely with the purpose of keeping
grass from growing in front of the
panels
it is a popular idea that sheep can be
grazed
but sheep also chew metal cables uh
sheep chew plastic
and these are incredibly expensive bits
of equipment
um added to which you have transformers
etc etc
with large signs saying keep away and as
far as i'm aware she can't read
um there will be
solar parks which do have sheep grazing
on them
without doubt but the vast majority of
them
are maintained by professional mowing
companies or ground maintenance
companies
who go along uh and know them i mean i
do my little bit on behalf
and the standards they require
incredibly high
um so yes theoretically all right
but this is traditionally arable land
and has been arable land for 40 years
it gets very wet in the winter as we
know
which of the plots of crops are planted
before then
isn't a problem but it means you cannot
put
um cloven-hoofed animals on there
because they will just
uh they'll get foot rot
thank you counselor dixon
thank you very much cancer cat thank you
chairman to um try to answer counselor
kettle's question about um
dates uh he was quite right the deppas
bridge
uh decision was in 2014. i'm afraid i
don't have the date for the decision on
the appeal
but the decision to refuse uh the
dappers bridge application was made by
this council in april 2014
so the court strategy was evolving at
that time
and the blackwell one the decision was
made by this council
in march 2015 so yet again
the core strategy was evolving at this
time but it hadn't been
adopted at this time and certainly
obviously the
the climate change emergency policy had
not been adopted at that time
thank you mr parker thank you
i've just gone off again here we go um
clarification points with the officer
anybody have any like any questions for
the officer
gosh stunned didn't go on councilman
yeah i'm going to say louise did a good
job then i thought you know
she's doing a very good job um louise i
just wanted could you
put the photos up from
the view from bert nesset hills for me
please
good
i think louise can actually zoom in on
that if it helps jim
oh there we go oh
that's better isn't it
what are you doing
can you run your cursor over where the
it will be so that's the year five
year one
i can't see the difference
yes it's even better
good can you do the game form because
the cursor on that
show the width yeah
so this is night clip bottom yeah along
here
okay what you're looking for actually
sorry what i should say
um point of clarification this area here
that was field nine this was uh provided
prior to the applicants taking
this section out so please discount this
this will be green
field so actually it's from here
to here yeah field nine's gone
and that is still but that is still 200
acres yes
it it's it's gone down to 58 points
56.8 hectares of land
with panels within it out of the 82.
obviously we've got some unused areas
now
any further questions for the officer
no okay right
members debate do you wanna i
can't say dixon beat you two is actually
but but we'll
you know we'll start with getting into
counseling tonight thank you thank you
chairman
um certainly obviously we we've passed
that climate change
um aim and target etc
um my own view on this one is that we do
need
to increase our renewable energy
sources and i also anticipate and see
here that there are new hedge grows
to be planted which will again improve
bio diversity of the area over and above
that which is currently there
understanding that it is arable uh use
at the present time
my anticipation is that arable will have
some
biodiversity and useful assistance etc
regarding
uh life but i suspect that life is not
quite as varied
as it would be with hedgerows and other
grass planting etc or could be as such
um i note the view from the burton
dassett hills
i'm a rambler it's not long since i was
on top of there
but there's also the m40
in view etc and as much as we can
zoom in um my recollection of when we
had to take photographs for
um purposes of viewpoints etc
um it had to be a standard for 50 ml
lens or whatever and no zooming in etc
and therefore i see it as a
sliver of potential uh silver
light reflecting glass at the distance
of
i think probably over two miles if it's
three kilometers something like that
and therefore there can be various
developments within the countryside
which
will have uh an initial detrimental
impact
but ultimately i can remember in our
climate change discussions
one of our councillors very forcibly
said
there are some hard decisions to be made
if we are going to meet our target
tonight it's a hard decision but i favor
the officer's recommendation of grant
thank you chairman thank you very much
cain's addiction
uh council mills was next and then we've
got councillor thank you
thank you thanks miss jim um yes i i did
go and look at this from uh
several viewpoints um
and i have to say uh for me it is uh
vandalism on a on a countryside in a
grand scale
the impact on the land is um
[Music]
for me is quite enormous uh visual
impact from
aomb um with without doubt you can
see it um i'm sure this is another place
we can put these
at these panels but for me in this
particular part of
warwickshire is um vandalism on a grand
scale thank you mr chairman
thank you cancer mills council curtis
thank you
um certainly actually i tend to agree
with
carlson mills on i mean this is a
an extremely large industrial unit um
i think solar farm is a slightly
misleading
term but i was particularly interested
in the comments from councillor kettle
on the loss of land for agricultural
purposes
we we do have a climate emergency yes
the council has adopted that absolutely
but it's not just about
energy generation and i think we should
consider
really seriously the loss
of agricultural land if we are
increasingly reliant on importing food
from halfway around the world there is a
massive impact on climate change
so i think that does need to be taken
into consideration very carefully
um i'm certainly not
against renewable energy i think it was
interesting to hear
that only 10 of renewables in the uk
come from solar
and for me particularly the scale of
this
um i just think is out of proportion as
it's been said um sorry i it's a point i
made earlier on
um uh
the council's renewable energy landscape
sensitivity
study for this area in scotland location
it exceeds the limit of landscape
sensitivity framework by 250 percent
of breach of policy cs3 it is a scale
that really concerns me and i think
as i say um councillor kettle's comments
are
worth listening to as always councillor
kevin
thank you thank you council curtis
uh coaster james
um to me the climate emergency means we
need more renewable energy
this is going to provide energy for
sixteen and a half
thousand how homes um there's always
going to be some sort of quit per quote
or drawback or
balancing act um when you have to make
these decisions
but in order to achieve clean energy in
my view it's something which we
should be ready we have to do as much as
we may not want to
we have to do it um and i've i've driven
past
a lot of these and i went down to
cornwall a couple weeks ago and i've
driven past a few of them there
and i personally don't find solar panels
offensive in any way i
quite like seeing the winner but uh
i think it's sort of i'd rather see that
you know some coal fired power station
being built somewhere
or any other form of unrenewable
energy um we're not losing we wouldn't
be losing it
to agriculture cheap farming is
agriculture um we're talking about
having to bring food in from all around
the world well
we're talking new zealand was mentioned
well have you guessed what we bring in
from new zealand
sheep so forgotten sheep farming here
it's sort of we're not losing anything
um
and again it's for a 40-year license on
this application
um i'm sure when technology changes i
mean it may well be before then
that they decide to to get rid of it
because there's another form of
cheaper um energy source
um so it could revert back to crop
farming
i mean when i say as an arable farming
before that date
but it's not being lost to agriculture
it's still being used
and could be used for agriculture with
the sheep farming
so therefore you say it's hard decisions
have to be made
and you've got to balance this up and on
my balance i'd bounce i
i agree with the officer's
recommendation and i'm happy to propose
that
we go ahead and grant this application
thank you very much casa jennings
council hence the seraphim
thank you chair i agree with councillor
mills
and councillor curtis i have
reservations of using up
agricultural land when there could be
possibility of
other sites i've looked at this over a
number of years
and if you take a car park where
tesco's supermarket is you could cover
that
as a roof with solar panels
and it wouldn't have any detrimental
effect because it's not taking up
any more room there's lots of car parks
like that
industrial sites as well so um
i agree with the council mills and
cancer courtesy this is too much to lose
on agricultural land thank you
cancer thank you chairman
councillor jennings has proposed a grant
i would
second that proposal
thank you council dixon okay so we have
a
motion to grant um from my perspective
um it's balance and
i'm very finely balanced i'm not sure
where
where i particularly want to go with
this and listening to these debates
it doesn't make it any easier for me
because looking at the six people around
here
we you know we're almost in a 3-3 so
i think what we'll do is we'll move to a
vote and and see where we go with that
so the most the the proposal we've got
is that uh
we grant in line with the officer's
recommendation so
uh can we have a show of votes please
all those in favor that's two chairman
thank you all those against
that's three chairmen three against
abstention
abstain it's two abstentions
okay
proposal refuses um
due to the impact on the land and
openness
we do that yeah thank you
um if you're considering refusing this
application
you must have reasons why you feel the
application
doesn't meet with your policies so i
think what i'm
hoping to hear from members um before we
start to talk about a reason for refusal
is how the harms that they've identified
relate back to your policies um
and i think we need to draw more out of
what has already been said
so that i can i can help you to draft
your reasons for refusal okay sorry
that's really all i can say
well thank you i mean i say for my part
um at the impact on the land uh
is in a on a grand scale
um it's just the impact i mean i i say i
view this from several
viewpoints and
trying to imagine it looks horrendous so
it for me is the impact on the land
itself
thank you perhaps is that good enough
yeah i'll tell you what we're going to i
think what we're going to do here
chairman
is we're going to have a look at policy
cs3
about that let's have a look at cs3 i'll
get it up on the screen
and then you can see how you think this
application
relates to policy cs3
this could take me a moment please bear
with me because i haven't got the core
strategy open
there's plenty there mr
what was that
you just bear with us while we find the
right piece of information please
obviously i'm happy to take whatever
members want to tell me but i'm
trying to help you to formulate your
reason by showing you
what what i i understood from the debate
you can't get it up controlling
the screen it'll be a second or two
that's better yeah thank you
so if you go through to the next page
whoever's controlling this
here we go we start to talk about solar
energy and we start to talk about the
criteria that we're going to use to
judge solar proposals against
um there you go impact on agricultural
activities
and disturbances to agricultural land
impact on openness and character of the
landscape
impact on the character of the historic
landscape trees enhanced biodiversity
and direct and reflected lighting
so help me with that but pull something
out of that um
counselor you said the impact on the
land um
i i i know that we will be tested
on that phrase in the future what sort
of impact
i mean do you mean the impact on this
paragraph here isn't that isn't that
good enough
so you simply feel that it fails on all
of those counts well
i would say so that it's going to have
an impact on the current sheep grazing
on the land
that it's going to have an impact on the
openness
impact on
yeah i would say all that
thank you thank you
i think can i just chair i think our
members would should maybe focus on the
second bullet point
is what i'm hearing i think impact on
openness and character of the landscape
and visual immunity that seems to me to
be the main
concern rather than some of these other
points okay if that if you're happy okay
yeah
okay thank you thank you ross right
so we've got a proposal from councilman
mills we've been seconded by
councillor curtis can we go for a vote
on
to to refuse then please
it's in favour that's three in favor of
reviews
again all those against please
two against any abstentions
that's two abstentions chairman
i know so
thank you mr
yeah application number two zero oblique
so o2839
stroke ful has been refused
thank you that was hard work
it's easier than i expected to be honest
okay we're going to adjourn just for a
couple of minutes that was quite a long
drawn out one we'll have a couple of
minutes and then we'll start again
right ladies and gentlemen we're going
to move on to item five
item two zero oblique stroke oh three
five eight five let me get the number
right here
uh lock up garages hudson road
stratford-unhaven
i invite the planning officer amy flute
to present the application
thanks amy thank you chairman
the application site and represented by
the black dot on the map is a former
garage site within the defined built-up
area boundary of stratford
outline planning permission is sought
within the area edged red for up to five
dwellings
including demolition of existing garages
and the redevelopment of the existing
hard standing
and one two bed house with amenity space
the existing access of hudson's road
would be utilized
parking and turning would be provided to
the south of the site
as well as a pedestrian link to the
existing footpath to the east
looking in the south easterly direction
from hodgson's road
the site's access can be seen
the image on the left shows the access
road as it curves to the left on the
immediate approach to the garage site
as you are within the site and the image
on the right shows the curve in the
opposite direction
if you were to exit the site
this image is taken within the site
looking in a northwesterly direction
the access ray can be seen as can the
relationship of the site with the
neighboring properties that front onto
hodgson's road
now looking in a north easterly
direction the existing garages can be
seen
again the relationship of this site with
neighbouring properties on maple grove
can also be seen the eastern boundary of
the site
is now being shown there is an existing
pedestrian footpath which links the site
between hodgson's road
maple grove and kenneth close
this image is taken from the access
looking in north westerly direction
towards hodgson's road as you exit the
site
and finally these images show hodgson's
road from the access point
please be aware of the updates on the
update sheet
it um in office's view it has not been
demonstrated that there is a safe and
suitable access to the site for all
users
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
the application based on highway
concerns as detailed within the
committee report
thank you thank you amy
and we've a couple of speakers on this
one
okay first speaker is mr mike jones
who's the agent
you've got three minutes mr jones and
we'll give you a 30 second warning
of when your time's about to run out
thank you
right okay thank you um the officer's
report
is fairly comprehensive and i don't
really want to go through any aspect of
it
i think it's safe to say that there is
one
uh issue which has been raised which amy
referred to right at the end and that is
the highway access
my concern really here is that i have a
disagreement with the highway authority
and particularly how it has conducted
itself
and how it keeps changing its view in
the consultation response it originally
set out on the 11th of february
it actually had although it raised an
objection it was
purely on the grounds of refuse
and in terms of the access it said the
application site has been used
historically for the parking of vehicles
therefore the existing access route has
encountered significant use
the proposal will result in lower or
comparable vehicle
vertical movements then that would be
generated in full use of the garages
the access width is suitable
we then came further on to
april and may when amy tried to contact
the highway authority
and the highway authority send various
emails i don't need to go through them
they're in the committee report but
the highway authority basically has
changed its position
first of all claiming that there was a
public footpath going through the site
we did check this right at the beginning
there is no public right of way and the
right-of-way officer has no objection
what seems to be the case is that there
is a highway maintained at the public
expense which is
unbeknown to us and number known also to
the district council
who are who actually are the owners of
the site and were the
uh the or worthy of society who sold it
to
my client um the situation
now has moved on the highway authority
we have to do road safety audits the
road safety audits fair no
issues but the highway authority have
taken issue with the width of the access
which obviously amy has shown
the access that you saw actually has
vegetation on one side which will be
removed so the width actually will be
increased
so having found that the access width
and the the number of vehicles moving
was satisfactory in february
the latest position on the 30th of july
from the highway authority
is completely opposite and in putting
that
forward it actually now says that there
will be intensification of use
the problem is
so it seems like the problem is the
highway authority have completely
discounted
the historic use of the site and are
assuming that the site is
vacant and has no vehicle activity which
of course is complete nonsense
it you can't you can't compare
the proposed use with the site which is
now vacant the site is vacant because
orbit sold it and the garages obviously
are not used
so my position is that the highway
authorities position
is is muddled and is wrong
and there are no other reasons for
refusal
you had a time listen thank you
right anybody have any questions for mr
jones
mr councilman we'll go with him forever
thank you hi hello mr jones um
you say that the um access air going to
be widened
um by how much
uh i should know uh it's about a meter
and a half i think it's
it's the hedge which is going down the
side the actual
property was owned by the garages were
owned by orbit
the the access and the hard standing
were owned by the district council now
it's all owned by my my client
orbit also in the house on the left-hand
side
um so but the council's ownership
includes the hedge
and that goes down the left-hand side
you're looking at it
so that would be removed to widen the
axis
uh council dixon was next i think thank
you chairman
um basically i was it was the same topic
so
um uh mr jones basically that hedge that
we're seeing there
uh is not on the ownership and the
property
that we can see that house it belongs on
the driveway
on the left-hand side that's correct yes
thank you
any other questions from mr jones case
of curtis bob
thank you i'm sorry still the same point
but do we know
or can you say what the width of that
driveway would be
were that hedge to be removed because i
think that's very critical
sorry it's a very good question and i
should have the answer i
i think it's in the if i'm
not mistaken it was actually commented
in the committee report which i'm trying
to
get to
from memory is i think it's a i think
it's a one and a half meters but
but i i'd have to uh we've got a
topographical survey which basically
picks it up
so the the actual ownership boundary is
is a
is a um a
fence behind the hedge if that makes
sense
but i don't have on me i'd apologize the
exact
width of the access drive
once you've removed the hedge it's
certainly in the information we supplied
to
uh to amy as the planner
yeah i think amy's got it on the planet
it's shown it's three and a half meters
so miss jim that is the finished size is
it
thank you
thank you
next speaker is the ward member
councillor foytec
cancer before you take you got five
minutes and give you 30 seconds warning
when you're approaching the time
thank you very much um yeah i'm speaking
to
support the planning officer's
recommendation to refuse
this application um and also
that wcc highways have made an objection
because of the um size of the access i
just really just want to give you a
little bit of historical
sort of sort of background to to the
area really
somewhere i've lived all my life so i
know it very well
and the garages were first put in about
40 years ago
um and they were used as garages but
over a period of time
they actually became sort of plate
lockups where people would take storage
so there'd be
perhaps one or two car movements in a
week so
it's over the decades the car movements
have reduced
however thomas jolly school at the very
top
their main entrance um uh
you i don't think you can see the
pictures of it if you go the alleyway
that takes you
up past maple grove and kenneth close
it actually brings all the chil a lot of
the children actually go to school
out to the entrance of the school so for
the past
30 years my own children have been there
so for the last 30 years
the school's doubled in size um
movements of children has increased over
those years as well
not only that tesco has developed a back
entrance
which leads to a lot of parents parking
at tesco
they're encouraged to walk their kids to
school and so they go through the back
of tesco
through this this very narrow
entrance to this alleyway and then
on to school and in fact on the
14th of july one of the residents
actually pictured
everybody that used that for a half hour
period between 3 15 and 3 45
and there were 122 movements so that's
children on
bikes on scooters
the way kids sort of move around they
sometimes walk into school on their own
and and as they come out of that very
tight entrance
right opposite is a play area so there's
a great incentive
for for the um for the kids to use the
alleyway and it's
it's actively encouraged so to actually
put
a building there with a shared the only
way you could actually
use the entrance to access housing is to
share the carriageway
whereby really if you're going to use it
it would be in my my
humble opinion that you'd probably need
a separate pathway and a road
to access otherwise um i don't think it
will be
safe and that's that's pretty much where
i'm at
if you've got any questions please
please ask any questions
thank you thanks for watching and we've
got any questions
no no questions you get up lightly
thank you very much
clarification thank you yes please um
just do that
sit somewhere else
that's better um amy uh
to put a roadway let's say that that's
um
edges of a car so it's going to be used
would we
legally need a footpath
thank you
um that's something that i'm not a
hundred percent sure on myself
highways haven't picked up in um haven't
obviously said that in their comments i
don't know if dale's got anything he can
add to that at all
as to whether whether we would legally
need um to have a footpath alongside
i i really wish we got a highway
engineer here
um jimin you'll be
aware that we on on large housing
layouts
we regularly bring schemes to you where
five houses maybe as many as nine or ten
houses
operate off a shared surface yeah which
is is shared by pedestrians and by
vehicles yeah and they're designed to be
sufficiently wide to have sufficient
visibility so that and obviously to
operate at sufficiently slow speeds
that both vehicles and people can can
use them
safely together so
i think the answer to your question is
it is possible to do that
uh the highway authority clearly
concluded that it's not possible to do
that
in this instance does that answer the
question
did the best i could
uh okay addiction i think was first
yeah see sneaked in behind you
thank you chairman um amy um
is there a minimum distance that uh we
should be looking at
for as it were one-way traffic because
that's obviously a narrow entrance even
with the removal of that hedge
and uh obviously we are assured it
belongs to
the council and not that owner who has
probably been trimming it for a number
of
years in that adjacent house um but
essentially
i'm looking at uh what happens when one
vehicle
is exiting and another vehicle is trying
to get in
um obviously there's no um passing
points it's pretty narrow
and it looks fairly long um i just
wonder if you can give us the exact
length
and whether or not it is too long
for single carriageway
okay i can i can measure off the length
of the access for you
um in a moment but i think the one of
the
highways um objections within the update
sheet may actually answer the question
so they've said that the access is a is
of insufficient whip at the junction
with washington road to enable vehicles
traveling in the opposite direction to
pass
this could lead to head-on type
collisions or a vehicle reversing out
onto a live footwear carriageway
which could lead to vehicle and
pedestrian conflicts resulting in
injuries
the highway authority would require the
axis to be constructed to a minimum whip
of 5 meters for the first 7.5 metres
as measured from the near edge of the
public highway carriageway
thank you amy thank you very much german
okay so jenny thanks sir
amy i think that a lot of what i was
going to ask you was the same
so therefore that it needs to be it
needs to be five but that's actually
three and a half
the other thing was
do we have yep um so
county um council rights of way have um
stated that there's no
um designated public footpath but there
is
um a footpath which appears to run
through the site which
um as the ward member was referring to
um which connects the site maple grove
and it's close
um and then runs allows people to access
through the site onto hodgson's road
um which from the highways comments
which suggests that it is
um highway managed it's um highway
managed at the public expense
so if i go back to my photos so this
this is the site access hodgson's road
um and then when you get into the sites
and so then this is where the road on
the left curt would curve round
and then this is obviously the central
part of the site
and then um the footpath then which is
existing which connects
up um to kenneth's close and goes up to
the top road
and can then be seen which is there at
the moment
okay any other question i've got a
question if i may
um so with regards to refuse there were
there was an objection um and refuse
collection
if members were minded to approve could
potentially be and dealt with by
condition um for a refuge strategy
strategy to arrange an alternative form
of refuse collection from the site where
we could get the details of the size of
the vehicles the times
to ensure that something could fit
comfortably um i can show you
a um tracking plan that's being provided
which shows for an
ambulance and um
a fire and tender vehicle um i'm not
sure whether the size of the vehicle
is what it what serves the site um
so obviously you can see see from that
um
the tracking into and out of the site um
highways have
um obviously made comment um in their
numerous
um consultation responses about
obviously how the site needs to be able
to be accessible to a variety
of of vehicles
and in their most recent
objection they have um stated
obviously how there is the potential for
um conflict between vehicles and how it
hasn't been demonstrated that a safe and
suitable access to the site can be
achieved for all users
for clarity to chair if i may um
emergency vehicles tend to find a way
you know whatever the conditions
emergency vehicles tend to find a way
refuse collection the position is very
simple the
council's street cleaning people
have said they will not collect refuse
from here so the only way that refuse
can be collected
is by a private arrangement uh i i i'm
not sure that was clear in amy's answer
that's correct isn't it thank you okay
thank you amy anybody get any further
questions
ah country crumb yeah it's certain just
point to clarification about the
emergency vehicles
that my portfolio county i've got fire
and rescue
and any delay any can be vital
so i would like to ensure i'll take on
point mr barca said that the fire
engines fire appliances would get there
but any delay can be vital
so that's that's one point i need to
make sure we've
got that we need to turn into account so
um
whilst i i can understand mr parker's
points and it is true that they will get
there by hook or by crook or where you
can use that phrase these days so
apologies if it's the wrong phrase
but they will get there by any means um
but yeah any any delay
by a minute or two could be have tragic
consequences so
therefore i will make sure we we are on
the safe side of caution
thank you very much casa crum any other
questions now
okay so now we've got a point to
clarification
move on to debate uh oh crikey they're
all
good cancer dixon go you first
thank you chairman uh the officer's
recommendation was to refuse
i would propose that it is refused in
accordance with the officer's
recommendations
i'm quite happy to second that um this
is all about access
i know highways have changed their mind
a number of times
as far as the actual five dwellings are
not a problem i
wouldn't have a problem with that at all
uh yeah the problems the access
i think the applicant probably needs to
go back try and sort out
something with highways and then come
back
thank you country james councilman
thanks uh mr chairman
yeah i i'm just looking at the
[Music]
wc highways objection and just to read
it this could lead to head-on collisions
on which
aim is read out vehicles reversing out
them to a live footwear
and and um it said pedestrians conflicts
resulting in injuries
if we if we were to grant this
and there were injuries we'd be held to
pay uh we really would
um we as a as a council we couldn't do
it
as an authority thank you
yeah thank you mr chairman yeah taking
into account cancer vortex points about
safety children using it etc
and the 120 movements between 315 and
345
and also the objections from the county
on the 19th of july on the 30th the
september 30th of july
i've not seen anything to make me go
against officers recommendations to
reviews so
i will go along with the proposal
right so we've moved to a vote we've
already got a proposal and a second
uh those in favor of uh refusing in line
with the
officer's recommendation
it's unanimous chairman okay thank you
very much everybody
so i can now confirm that application
number two zero stroke o
three five eight five so obt has been
defeated
has been agreed that uh it will be
refused
application number 2002 489
ful riverside caravan park titlington
road
tidington stratford i invite the
planning officer sarah mcpherson to
present this application
thank you sarah thank you chair this
application is at riverside caravan park
on tiddington road
just outside stratford it's identified
here by the black dots in the center of
the map
this is the site in greater detail it's
important to note that parcel b
and c outlined in blue on this map are
excluded from the red line boundary
we're only concerned with parcel a
and here is the site when seen from
above
that's about it for uh images to show
you so back to this one
um the current lawful use of the site
has been established
they can have 266 caravans of any type
for seven months of the year between
april and october
the proposal is to reduce the number of
caravans to 180
and extend the occupancy period for 10
months of the year
that would be between march and january
thank you chair oh the recommendation is
to approve
thank you sure before you proceed can i
draw members attention specifically
to the update sheet page three
uh i'm carrying over onto page four
where there is
a request from uh that the
due to the ward members serious medical
condition
uh that the application is deferred to
allow her to
to be present and to uh speak
and give her her um constituents views
on the application
which is followed then by uh some
comments from the applicant
explaining the difficulties that that
would cause to him
so request for deferral and response
from the applicant
both of which i think members should
really read and understand before they
proceed to debate
thank you
thank you the
only speaker we have on this is uh mr
nick allen
the applicant um if you'd like to come
forward mr
ahn you have three minutes and we'll
give you a 30-second warning when your
time's running out
um
thank you very much chairman councillors
uh my name is nick allen i'm
i'm uh the director of avon estates
which own the
uh holiday parks we're probably one of
the largest fittest accommodations
in stratford-upon-avon we have about 80
000 guests each year
and 28 full members of staff who
actually work on just these sites
um planning permission to operate as a
carbon site at riverside go
back to the 1970s there's no planning
condition to limit the type of number of
caravans use the land
it currently has a mix of touring and
statics a certificate of lawfulness
demonstrated the physical capacity to at
least 266
it was limited to seven months of the
year at other parks that we run avon
park and radio park
are all 10 months of the year so during
the last few years with the increase of
people staying in the uk holidays
demands have increased for better
quality accommodation
and week-long bookings on the other hand
there's been a decrease in touring
caravan bookings that stratfor
set for the pune even accordingly this
playing our person seeks to limit the
number of caravans to the size of up to
180
whilst increase the period of occupancy
from seven to ten months
the trade-off will equalize the flood
risk to holiday makers
and there's no objection for the
environment agency
there'll be no change to the carbon site
boundaries or further development of
roads hard selling or buildings
visual impact will be reduced because
fewer caravans will be spread across the
sites
a longer holiday season will provide
many public benefits
riverside will employ more staff and
ground maintenance cleaners and
management
clubhouse income and staff is likely to
increase a longer season and a higher
occupancy rate will benefit the tourism
economy of stratford-upon-avon
and tiddlington by the lengthening of
our season
i therefore ask you to support the
officer's recommendation and grant plan
commission
thank you very much for australia thank
you
does anyone have any questions from mr
allen counselor dixon
mr allen um the officer didn't say what
uh parcel would be
pass or c i used for obviously not part
of the application site
are they in but they are in the
ownership of an estates
uh are there any caravans on those at
all i just wonder
yeah they're excluded from anything so
parcel b
and parcel c was under certificate of
lawfulness and they've got
planning permission for residential park
homes for 365 days a year
any other questions mr allen okay sir
jennings
how dependent is your business um
from this extended holding career
um i suppose our industry has gone
through a few changes in the last couple
of years especially
and with the pandemic
it's not the be-all or end-all of our
world but what has
what it will produce is is more
customers coming we'll
extend our season will allow us to run
our parks
probably more efficiently but the the
way that the industry has gone now
is um touring has
um with the 56-day rule that the
government's put out
has definitely been spread out more
farmers and anyone with land can
actually now
have a caravan site on their land so we
have definitely seen a dip of interest
on that
and a massive increase for holiday
homes for for weekly bookings
so it is it is important to us
thank you
any other questions from mr allen
well i'll i will ask one as well um
we've had you've heard uh mr barker talk
about this potential deferral and
whatever else
you've made quite a strong statement
about this potential deferral
um and just if you could just give us a
very brief
uh explanation of why you've got to wait
for two years if we if you don't get
this
decided today
um it's we it's like a building site i
suppose
um that we we have to we this won't be
done by ourselves these these lodges uh
or the bases put in um we will have to
get outside contractors to
come in and start soon as you can
imagine the industry is manic
the longer i put it off the the longer
time i'm not going to get
ground crews to be able to come in and
do it um
i have got quotes done and i've got
hopeful start dates but i i can't put a
spade in the ground
um unless the application gets gets put
through and it will put us back
definitely to 2023 even probably longer
the industry is is manic at the moment
and also guessing holiday homes um you
know
we have to put orders in if we go and
order some stuff now
it's getting delayed and delayed and
laid and we all know that at the end of
the day we can't get
building materials it's the same for the
cowan industry we are struggling the
same
okay thank you very much for that thank
you oh hang on we've got another
question councillor dixon
thank you chairman um you just used the
word lodges there
uh mr allen um obviously we know that
there's touring caravans and static
caravans
you obviously got some park homes in
parcels b and c
are these lodges wheeled vehicles as a
caravans
or are they something more affixed
um with uh our we've got a typical
lawfulness for
for caravans uh the lodges that i'm
referring to
are uh caravans on wheels
so it comes under the same definition it
does yes yeah
we can have either a static carbon with
an aluminium clad
or we can go for a a lodge effect
uh unit which is more in keeping
same unit because obviously a park home
itself has to have a chassis
i need to be mobile park home is a
caravan yeah so it's the same unit but
we are
it just makes them that they we try and
do our developments all the same color
it just makes it a lot more
um pleasing to the eye thank you
okay thank you very much mr allen
yeah uh clarification from the officers
thank you very much
sorry i had a brief lapse there and i
couldn't think what it was
uh clarification of the officers
thank you chairman um on
the planning application and information
is a park home and caravan touring fixed
the same animal in other words in
reducing the number of
statics and touring vans down
the site of a could they all become
park homes without any further planning
application
having to be submitted if we approve
this one this evening
at the moment um it's been established
through the lawful development
certificate
that they can have 266 caravans that is
of any type that can be a touring
vehicle or a static
caravan they would have to fit the legal
definition of a caravan
which i think ross is able to define
further if you need further
clarification
um but a a static caravan a park home
type thing
that does fit within that definition
they can have up to 266 of those
um the same parameters would apply under
the planning
application where they're requesting 180
of those
so there wouldn't be any change to the
type of unit they could have on site it
would just be the number which we're
looking at today
yes if they fail within the legal
definition of a caravan yes
thank you dixon any other questions for
the officer
no okay then we'll move to debate
now um as dale's already said on the
debate
we have a request
on deferment on this but let's debate
first and then we can make a decision
on on what we're going to do when we've
had a debate
okay and councillor jennings you go on
okay then i absolutely understand
uh sorry chair i think it makes sense to
decide whether you're deferring first
before you debate you know yeah
thank you for that
is there any course for it to do for her
counselor yes mr chairman i would like
this to be deferred
um until such time we can have
the uh war member or ward members
representation to uh come to committee
thank you
is that a proposal that's proposal
we have any seconders for that proposal
council hence the seraphin propose your
second
this is to give uh councillor ralph the
opportunity
she's invested a lot of work in this so
this is to give her the opportunity to
play her case
and uh so i think what we'll do is we've
got a proposal in a second that
uh we'll go to a vote to prefer cherry
for me before you go to a vote
that's a very open-ended resolution
until such time as the ward member
is able to attend or supply her
representation yeah
can we can we nail that down a little
bit tighter absolutely that is very very
open
yeah yeah i i i thought that when i said
it clearly it is a bit open
um until we can
can we get this to a committee
quickly and by then i mean we've done um
we can get uh how about delegating that
decision to the chairman
chairman to negotiate not not this
chairman
the chairman of the committee mr
richards councillor richards
to negotiate with the ward member and to
agree with the ward member
a date when it can come back
um it wouldn't be appropriate i don't
think for officers to have that
responsibility but it would be
appropriate for the chairman to have it
yeah and he would
obviously balance the needs of mr allen
against the needs of the ward member and
it would be his decision
obviously we'd give him advice sounds
good to me
let's do that okay so delegate it to
the the full chairman delegate full
chairman
to negotiate with board member and
forward with the day
okay so can we have a vote to go with
that then please
that's one two three four chairman yeah
those against that
that this is and that's three against
chairman
so okay so carried to defer
until uh the
[Music]
proper committee chairman has a
discussion with the ward member
and take it forward from there just it's
really just to clarify her recovery
period is
that's just when we can reschedule this
okay right
wow
okay
sorry for that morning delay agenda item
seven
two zero stroke oh three four four three
stroke very edencroft
fells lane napton on the hill oh amy's
gone
thank you chair all right it says i
invite amy flute to present but
so are you doing this one i i am
please proceed louise thank you you're
doing a very good impression yeah i'm
gonna
need curly hair but other than that
thank you chair
yes um this application is in relation
to
a site in napton on the hill which is
identified by the black dot
on the map the site is located off
fells lane which is a single track road
this is fells lane
here identified which links on to dog
lane
um and this is the site here
so just looking up so it gets no
actually it's about
there this is the access
and this is the area of concern um
planning permission has been granted
previously by committee
for uh the erection of a self-filled
three-bedroom
house workshop in garaging as you can
see on the aerial photograph
it's the house and the garage and
workshop are already in situ
access parking plus improvements to fel
lane
have also been approved as part of that
application
including improved resurfacing um a
turning head and a passing bay
within fells lane this was granted
in 2019
uh the applicant uh then after obtaining
permission uh wish to carry out some um
minor alterations to the design of the
house and the garage
um this was then subsequently approved
last year
and a very application which is 24 slope
zero zero five seven four very um and in
that application that also
include the um road improvement work
so that effectively entails
um 100 meter section of the road to be
resurfaced and widened to three meters
this new
indivisible passing bay some drainage
grips along the western side of the road
and the access to the house being
required to be a width of 5.5 meters
for a distance of 7.5 meters from the
carriageway
as i say works have commenced with
respect to this permission
and the highways require these works to
be completed prior to the occupation of
the property
now what we are considering as part of
this application relates
purely in relation to those road
improvement works
what the applicant has tried to achieve
is
minimize the impact on the
on fell's lane by reducing
the extent of measures so what they are
proposing to do
is remove the road widening and
surfacing
remove the drainage grips and also
reduce the width of the access to 3.5
meters instead of 5.5
to uh to
gain access into the application site
so just reiterating this has already
been approved previously
um the uh the applicant
in terms of this application has
submitted a road safety order at the
request of the highway authority
and and on the basis of this the highway
authority
are now supportive of the removal of
these additional
improvement measures however are quite
clear
that they would not support the removal
of the passing bay
um
turning now to photographs so
i've got the icon the blue blue arrow up
there
and denotes the line of sight so this
is you can see the house and the
workshop and garage
are all complete this is fells lane
along here
now this is looking at this you can
follow the arrow blue arrow along
this is looking up a long fells lane
um getting towards the application site
um the application site itself
and then looking in a southerly
direction
back against yourself down the lane now
this is the area of contention this is
the proposed uh
passing bay location um looking at an
aluminum
and a southerly direction and then
this is where uh further on um looking
in a northerly direction now
um where the existing houses are to
to the left-hand side um there's a
grouping river four
five four or so houses um there
so there are a number of updates and i
would draw your attention to the
comments
um from the ward member in particular
um where he is stating that on balance
he would like to see the
very application approved as it
conserves the appearance and character
of fells lane
far more than the original and varied
application obviously there's additional
comments now i'll let you read those
um the recommendation is to
grant subject to the um
conditions and notes and also there's
within the update sheet there is a
slight update to the wording of
condition for thank you chair
thank you louise
we've got three speakers on this one
and we've got the right name
objecting
you've got uh three minutes cancel a
good room
and we'll give you a 30 second warning
when you come to the end of your time
30 seconds left
perfect timing thank you very much uh
anyone have any questions for a
councillor goodroom council memphis
thank you very much um yes i was tempted
to drive down there but i didn't
um
well wasn't sure why they get stuck um
but he's one way isn't it
because when i i i was at the bottom
when i
you know went around the village and got
to the bottom and fell saying
i'm pretty sure it says
my mistake i wish i've driven it now
thank you councilman does anybody have
any other questions
thank you thank you chair uh council
just wondering um
you suggested i think that the uh
the the addition of a passing place
would
see increased traffic i just wonder if
the parish council has
any evidence to support that
thank you anybody else have a question
well i've i've got one if only
um so without a pass in place
if two vehicles meet one coming up the
lane one coming down the lane
does somebody then have to reverse that
onto another main road
to allow that to allow them to
which pass more
okay thank you very much for that thank
you
okay
next speakers uh mr roy hammond the
agent
and michael sanchez the applicant you've
got three minutes in total so decide
yourselves
how you want to cut that how you want to
carve that up
um
[Music]
um our eco build is now nearing
completion and we are proud
that most of our eco build principles
have been
achieved we're trying to minimalize the
impact on the environment in the
community and we've achieved an epc
grade a score for the property have a
sizable
underground rainwater tank and those
sort of features
uh what we are targeting so we thank the
officers for their support and would ask
the committee to
also support our request for this
amendment so that we don't
need to tarmac the middle section of the
lane which would make two thirds of it
tarmacked
um we believe that the condition that
was insisted
by wcc was erroneously put in place
because of
this misunderstanding about the refuse
trucks needing them
uh the rural essence of the character of
the lane
we believe should be preserved and
vehicle
use on the lane is minimal
i in all the time we've been there we've
yet to have
two vehicles going in the opposite
direction so and tarmacking
fundamentally is against the principles
of what we're doing trying to keep up
an eco-friendly house i'm happy to
answer questions after
i'll hand over to okay
okay mr hammond yeah
my apologies thank you for the
opportunity to speak
i'm roy hammond and i speak on behalf of
mr sanchez the first
thing i'd like to pick up on just just
to make it clear there's
been lots of talk about the passing
place the passing place has already been
approved by your council and
i mean and whether my client likes it or
not that passing base
passing place needs to be provided
we welcome the officers report and
recommendation for approval
and i simply wanted to highlight that we
felt very early on
that the required works were
disproportionate to the development that
was proposed
and would result in a considerable
harmful change
in what at the moment is a very quiet
rural
lane the changes proposed scale back
those works considerably
without undermining highway safety and i
welcome
the support now of the highway authority
and at the same time
the rule that that character of that raw
lane which is identified as being an
important
place in the neighborhood plan would be
retained
i would just like to also pick up upon
the
complete comments from the highway
authority i know that they
are requesting final details of the
highway works to be agreed prior to
commencement of the works
i it's difficult to see what additional
information we could provide
and i would question whether we do
actually need to provide that further
information
the the council has uh wrote a road
safety audit
they have the they have the details
of uh the scaled back works i don't
believe
condition that additional part condition
for
is necessary mr and mrs sanchez are
close to completing their house
and we would be looking at potentially
another three months of delay
before the before they could get into
their new home
thank you chair thank you very much
right there there's any counselors yeah
okay councillor dixon go for it
uh good evening um just for my own
clarification
um first of all is it have you achieved
passive house
status and my second question is are you
wanting to put in that passing bay i
appreciate
it as approved but are you actually
wanting to do it
um we're close to passive house we're
not going to spend all the money to get
it certified
but things like the the air tightness
testing and stuff like that
we achieved with only half done we
achieved i think it was just
around two so we would be confident that
if we did go to the
expense of getting it passive house we
would just about squeak in
um and the other question was
no and what i would if we had to have it
then
what i would hope the wcc would
perhaps allow us to do it more in
keeping so that
as you've seen the lane is planings and
stuff like that so
something that perhaps would grow over
through lack of use
as a suggestion
okay next question ah chancellor crump
come on
hello again hi uh it just just confirmed
um
that obviously if this application was
refused you would refer back to your
original application
that's got the turning head and the
surfacing of
the road correct yeah that that's
correct so if
if you were to mind it to refuse
tonight's application then
the original wording and the condition
and the extent of those improvements
works would stand
can i just follow it and again touch on
cancer dixon's point
but this proposal the variation you've
gone along with keeping
the passing bay in line with the county
council's recommendation
yeah that's correct we we we didn't
as [ __ ] i know yeah okay yeah
all right i'm just clarifying so
everybody's clear basically without
leaving the passing bay
workshop county council highways
department would not have
approved us not tarmacking the surface
so
perhaps yeah i'll make no further
comment but yeah
questions for these gentlemen nope i
think you can
uh you're free to go then thank you very
much for your input
we'll move on to uh points of
clarification from the officer
does anybody have one of those yeah
could i just yeah councilman
thanks luis um no sorry not louise
english it's
a long it's a long day isn't it um
louise
um how much of the lane is it taking out
to put this pipe
passing bay in
we can see here it's um
4.8 meters let's see if i can yeah i
shall but i'm going to do my special you
there we go how about that there we go
so it's saying
it's a width of 4.8
meters for a distance of 6 meters
louise uh can we approve this one and
not accept the warwickshire county
council's recommendation
or requirement to have a passing bay
as as we keep on referring it's already
being approved so
no because um in in terms
of the the applicant's requirements the
highway authority would change their
recommendation to objection um if they
were to come forward with this
however there is a valid fallback
of the extant permission which already
has approved this
in this position
yeah i i don't know whether this is a
helpful thought chair
i'm trying to be helpful here
first of all it's not common
for members to want to go against the
recommendation of the highway authority
i appreciate that there may be occasions
but it's unusual
for you to choose to do that
in this instance we don't actually know
what the highway authority would say
because they haven't been consulted on
the removal of the passing bay
they've been consulted on the other
changes
um but i suppose with the cooperation of
the applicant
if you were to defer tonight and the
applicant was to amend his application
to include a mission of the parking bay
we could then consult the highway
authority highway authority could give
their view
and you could make your decision the
difficulty for the applicant is
that if the highway authority were
vehemently objecting
to removing the passing bay then
there's the possibility that you would
refuse his application that he doesn't
want refusing he wants it approved
for the bits that he wants um so i
suppose the third option
and i'm thinking on my feet here was the
third option
is to approve this as it stands and to
invite the applicant to apply again to
remove the passing bay
we don't know what the outcome would be
but we would at least go through the
process and we would have full knowledge
before making the decision
i i i have to interject i believe there
has been that discussion
about the highway authority's views
if the passing bay were to be re removed
and i think that was a discussion that
the applicants have already had
and they've made it very clear that they
will not support this
going forward without passing bay in
situ
they would not support the removal of
the um
the minimizing of the impacts of the
removal of the other improvement works
without this going forward we mean that
we we know that yeah absolutely
that is what we expect that is what we
think they will say
no they have all the decision makers
yeah they have said yeah
but you are the decision makers yeah so
i wouldn't recommend you to go down that
line
but if that's the line you want to go
down it's available to you
counselor you know it's a statement or a
question that is so apologies if it is
i thought we had to discuss what's in
front of us
not what's going to be there's nothing
in the actual
application to remove the passenger so
therefore what we've just
talked about last five minutes i think
is irrelevant unfortunately
okay so i don't know where you agree
with that that's the question
uh yeah i think i would entirely agree
with you counselor chrome you should
decide the application in front of you
yes
and the application and the outcome of
the application in front of you
if you will prove it is that the passing
bay will be built
if you refuse it the passing bay will be
built
and i think it's really important that
you know that whichever decision you
make
the passing day is still required
yes yeah no problem
okay
okay so any other questions for for the
officer
no okay then we'll move straight to
debate
it can can i just hold you just for one
second a minute
mr crump uh yeah i'm saying this
i know this very well it's in my candy
board and i've walked up and down that a
few times with my election leaflets
over the years still got the scars and
limped to prove it
um it's certainly a difficult one it's a
sensitive one
for the residents of napton and the
councillors and it's definitely caused a
lot of debate
and i know there's been lots of
discussions i'm sure louise and the case
officer will attest to that
the variation in my opinion is better
than the original application and
certainly preserves
the character the line far more than the
original application
um the turning head removal the surface
in less than the one-third reduction
uh to get to the one-third note
it is certainly far more beneficial on
that
i think the things can be done on on the
surfacing as well
um that hopefully um again will help try
and protect it
so whilst it's
never going to be 100 um right
it's never going to please everybody are
third on the balance
to support the application
is that a proposal yeah it's a proposal
okay so jen i'm happy to second that
okay thank you very much
so we've got a proposal we've got a
second
to to agree with the officers and
whatever
so
vote for those in favor
six chairman thank you very much
those against
none i'm abstaining
one extension thank you very much
right then ladies and gentlemen we've
got no urgent business
uh we can't start anything else now so
uh i'm going to close the meeting
thank you very much good job
i owe you a pint why did you promise me
we can get it done
no i kept the porcelain
you